he have a back-to-back situation Anaheim in La
he'll play one of those games so it gives the
veteran net minder a chance to think about the
long game this is a team the Panthers thinking
about the spring and a two onone early it's
the red hot Reinhardt Rodriguez what a save
by Blackwood right off the Hop hurdle here
he's number eight in the league he wins this
draw cleanly and then it's that turnover right
there great play by Reinhardt but tough turnover
the San Jose Sharks need to get those red line
get it deep instead it's an incredibly dangerous
highrisk two onone Rodriguez can't quite you
know hurdle throws it across but Addison had
come across to the middle Here Comes ler R in
shorthanded but he's all by himself fenland's
going to the chain that's a good that's their
top pairing Breakaway grin for the one nothing
lead high and wide this a perfect post power
play shift too for the Panthers they generated
a little bit talked about that that offense that
the Sharks weren't able to create lomberg shot and
score Ryan longberg and all that pent up
energy his second goal of the year after
a nice 12g goal season last year for the fourth
liner right after a power play they generated a
little bit of offense no goals but some chances
on the man advantage and then lomberg does an
excellent job you mentioned he comes out
in with a ball of energy and just buzzing
around and he's ble to jump on that loose Puck
another bad turnover from the San Jose Sharks
and lomber takes it right here back end he cuts
inside with the forand and then a quick snapshot
well you look at all those numbers too when you
look at at San Jose and stats get skewed when
you have two games that you give up 10 goals
whether you're the goalie or the team kachuck
has Bennett Bennett shot Sav by Blackwood rebound
another save on kachuck and the Sharks will reset
just over four minutes to go here in the first
they comes Carpenter he drops it back hoffen
the shot through traffic rebound hoffin there
and he [Applause] [Music] scores the former
Panther ties the game up and one oh it's been
sloppy but you look at what they've been able
to do it's a great cross ice dump and then the
sharks get on the horse they get the puck they
retrieve it and then they able to go on offense
they've been on defense even if they're in the
offensive zone they've been on defense that they
haven't had the puck and I think they do a really
really good job here it's Carpenter who initially
gets to the puck they go low to high and then able
to get some clean passes through the neutral zone
Here Comes Zena save in front by stolar rebound
is covered up as well so another good chance for
the sharks sharks continue on nice pressure here
Panthers looking to get it out here they come
Oliver Ekman Larson little chip pass towards
Lawrence he has it he's got room around Lawrence
in front nice kick save by Blackwood this is a
lethal power play with a lot of high-end talents
Veri barov rinhart and kachuck and all fill it up
emman larsson's the facilitator nice sauce from
kachuck shot rebound score and it's the red hot
Reinhardt Again Sam Reinhardt the hottest player
in the league 12th goal already and the Panthers
take a 2-1 lead on the power play he's they've
moved uh kachuck up to this release position on
the left side he has the the puck here move it
around good Puck movement and then it's just a
simple Puck to the net it's not even a hard shot
it comes in and reinhardt's there to backhand it
in Blackwood is there to make the save on
the East Coast that he was getting traded
and certainly takes some time to adjust to a new
team and they really need him here on the power
play to come up big Brandon looking for his first
goal of the Year finds zerin across [Applause]
score thas hurdle on the power play just his
third of the year but it brings a smile to his
face and it ties the game at two great Zone entry
and they come in with speed so often you see teams
come in and they they they are a little bit slow
to get set up they take their time they there's
no urgency there is urg here urgency here with
the sharks and you go from left to your top of
your screen here to the right all the way across
and then back through great move by hurdle and
you know you've got some great penalty Killers
you talked about it you got barov and Reinhard
out there who have been phenomenal hurdle
back to the point they're set up with the
extra attacker granley hurdle looking to take
the lead granley to the net just wide rebound
score Luke [Applause] [Music] cunon and the
sharks have taken the [Applause] lead good
job by them getting set up that you know what
they showed some patience in the neutral zone
you mentioned some of the changes they had a good
shot off the off the back wall there but you know
it's an interesting balance on the power play or
the man advantage in this situation where they
pulled the goalie to have patience and urgency
and they married both of them perfectly good
shock to the easy save by Blackwood he tracked
it all the way Reinhardt barov plays it off his
skates to his tape to emman Larson quick shot by
Veri big save by Blackwood Veri again kchu kchu
Veri score his 100th of his career ties the game
at three second power play goal for the Panthers
tonight has an opportunity to ice the puck he
doesn't get it off quick enough this Puck comes
to he gets it on his back and forehand instead
of just swiping it out that causes this all this
problems right there running around after it
when they get a chance at this point in the
game game management against a team that's hungry
for another goal they've already had a power play
goal 33 now with under nine to
go see how the Sharks respond
they fought so hard to take the lead but
now we're tied shot score Tommy stanland
redirection Kevin stanland in
front and we are 43 Panthers
now who comes in here and it's a great look
from here and that's a great tip high in the
zone nothing Blackwood could do this line lomberg
had their first goal they're creating a lot it's
a good easy uh shot from the point from binus and
you know sometimes that's all it takes he doesn't
put a lot onto it it's more of a little knuckle
ball comes in and then lomberg hustling around
too if you're the if you're the Sharks and you got
lomberg hustling last game on the NHL schedule a
fun and busy Tuesday night Sydney Crosby hatrick
another duck Victory another goal holy Nikes Sam
Bennett is on the score sheet and now you know
he's not getting a lot of help but there's it's
just a screenshot it's from outside it's a little
bit tricky and you can look at Sam Bennett in here
too he reads the puck while he strips the San Jose
Sharks players of that and then he just takes that
tricky shot doesn't again put it we're right down
the line what your eyes see Dave as the puck comes
up the wall well right right there I mean that's
just we almost need an overhead we almost need
an overhead camera on the blue line there after
the coach's challenge the play was determined to
be offside no goal okay they saw something so it
goes goes back to 4 to3 it's not a panther power
play and Paul Maurice was like all right Addison
kind of close quarters hurdle now sends it to Gren
hopped over a stick tough break and Reinhardt
can clear and barov will ice the game empty met
TW goal lead with 213 to go it's barov sixth of
the year and there was some quick Puck movement
and you're absolutely right it's a tough bounce it
is if the game of bounces of inches but that's a
tough one it bounces over his stick it is their
their home ice so they can't claim any foul but
just you know it's an interesting one and then a
good play by fory give it get give it over here's
Lal he he can get a freebie and he shoots It Wide
that'll do it so the Florida Panthers with win
number five in a row San Jose Sharks gave them a
battle they took the lead but Mackenzie Blackwood